foreign
[Music]
I'd like to know I am Daniel Miranda
associate speaker of some TV and some TV
Latino and I am very happy to be with
you again in this program
I am here by myself my colleagues cannot
join me this time
but I am glad that we can have again
this program for you
if you want to participate in this
program we have an email address where
you can send your question
and this is the email address TV at
subtv.org again TV the at some tv.org
in this program we try to do our best to
find an answer to your questions if
there is an answer
and as Pastor CA often says we are too
late in time to be speaking about fables
and traditions of men we want truth we
want the truth of the word of God
so with that promise we want to begin
with God's blessing so please bow your
heads with me as I pray
dear heavenly Father which are in heaven
we thank you very much for this program
that I like to know
you have you know Lord that your
children have sent their questions
and I do not pretend to know all the
answers
but I know you have the answers in your
word and I pray Lord that you may guide
us in the study of your word at this
time in the name of Jesus Amen
okay
okay the first question here comes from
Diane Carter and this question can give
us at least 10 programs a whole series
to be able to answer these questions so
I'll try to be uh
as simple as possible in my answer the
question is what is the sequence of
events between now and Jesus coming
Jesus Second Coming
I would like to know what's happening so
that I can share with others is the
latter rain being poured out yet
thank you and God bless
okay this is a very very important
question and as I said it could take us
several programs to answer this question
but
for this program's sake
I want to take you to Matthew 24 that I
believe is the most comprehensive
chapter in the Bible
where we find
the most organized sequence of events
and this is Jesus's prophetic sermon
that he gave on the Mount of Olives the
context of this sermon is after Jesus
leaves the temple for the last time and
he says that behold your house unto you
is left desolate
the disciples are shocked with Jesus's
words and then they show Jesus the
temple the great buildings and then
Jesus says unto them in Matthew 24.
verse 2 that there won't be Stone upon a
stone that shall be left or thrown down
and now the disciples are perplexed by
Jesus's words and they come to him on
the Mount of Olives and they ask him
tell us when will these things be and
what will be the sign of your coming and
of the end of the age or or the end of
the world
so in light of these two questions
when will these things be which things
the destruction of the Temple of
Jerusalem and what will be the sign of
your coming and of the End of the Age
that clearly points to the end of time
so Jesus answers these two questions in
one sermon so we can understand or we
can see this sermon as having a dual
application
so
verse 4
we see here in verse 5 the first sign
that Jesus spoke was they
uh deceptions of false christs and false
prophets
now before we even go further let me say
this first
how do we know that Matthew 24
is in sequential order well there is a
Greek word the word taute that is used
over and over here and is translated as
them about nine times I believe is this
word is being used in Matthew 24 which
describes sequential order so after this
then this and after this then that
so you will notice that there are
several of these expressions
in Matthew 24 that Jesus describes as
happening before and then after and then
after the point that he had mentioned
before so the first thing that he
mentions are false christs and false
prophets then he says you will hear of
words and rumors of words see that you
are not troubled for all these things
must come to pass but the end is not yet
so while there are deceptions while
there were some rumors of wars actually
where we are right now is between verses
four through eight because in the
question says where are we now so this
is where we are now and these things are
happening almost simultaneously there
are deceptions we have more false cries
and false prophets arising in the
Christian world and we will see these
signs even more and more clearly as we
near the end of time we're seeing worse
we're seeing rumors of wars
um Nations shall rise up shall rise
against nation and Kingdom against
Kingdom and there will be famines and
pestilence and earthquakes in various
places but then verse 8 says and all
these are the beginning of Sorrows
now verse 9 here we find the words then
then
they will deliver you up to tribulation
and kill you and you shall be hated by
All Nations for my name's sake
here is what Ellen White called the
little time of trouble because now here
there is persecution in the context why
is the persecution coming because all
these things are mentioned specifically
the earthquakes pestilences famines this
is going to affect the world especially
economically and socially and
politically therefore
the churches and politicians will blame
God's people because they would say that
it is because of them that these things
are happening in the earth and you can
read this actually in in the great
controversy where you find the same
sequence in chapter
35 in the impending conflict where you
find that what nay Satan is doing in
nature the famines the pestilences the
earthquakes which today we would call
climate change you know all these things
will be attributed to us so what do we
see first we see
signs in the natural world
and in the social world
and in the religious world in the
religious world we see deceptions
in the natural world we see natural
catastrophes in the political world we
see wars and rumors of wars
we also see famines pestilences
so these things are the ones happening
right now
and it says the beginning of Sorrows
that means that the situation will
worsen even more and when it reaches a
certain point of crisis
then we will be the ones that will be
blamed sometimes we think that this is
going to happen in the Sunday law but
this happens before because the Sunday
law here in Matthew 24 is found in verse
15. which is the abomination of
desolation so before the Sunday law
happens this is the sequence of the
things are going to happen we have the
little time of trouble
in this little time of trouble it says
that we'll build will be delivered up to
tribulation some of you will be killed
some of you will be hated by all and
then verse 10 and then many will be
offended
um will be betray one another and will
hate one another that were offended
is the same word that is used in the
parable of the sower when it comes when
you is in regards to the seed that falls
among the stones that represents those
who receive the Gospel quickly but
because they don't have Roots the Sun
comes tribulations trials and they are
offended they fall away so here we find
the shaking okay some won't be able to
endure and they will fall away they will
leave the church so here we have the
mighty shaking okay then again there
will be more signs false prophets uh
during this time also in verse 14 we see
that the gospel is being preached notice
verse 11 that again the word then is
used then many false prophets will rise
up and deceive many okay and then this
Gospel of the Kingdom this is the Three
Angels messages will be preached in all
the world as a witness
uh to All Nations and then the end will
come verse 15 then we have the Sunday
law okay the abomination of desolation
and then the last opportunity to leave
the cities
and then we find here
that uh verse 21
it says for then again the word then is
here tote there will be Great
Tribulation such as has not been since
the beginning of the world until this
time no nor ever shall be so this is the
Great Tribulation and then we continue
reading
in verse 23 in the context of the Great
Tribulation it says then if anyone says
to you look here is the Christ or there
do not believe it so this is Satan's
counterfeit of the second coming which
in the context of Matthew 24 will happen
is during the time of trouble actually
when you read the great controversy the
chapter entitled the time of trouble
alien Y is following this same sequence
and it is in that chapter where she
describes Satan's counterfeit of the
second coming then we find the signs of
Jesus is coming and immediately verse 20
29 says immediately after the
tribulation of those days the sun will
be darkened and the moon will not give
its light we should not confuse these
signs as the as the signs of Joel which
happen in the 18th century these are
similar signs that will happen prior to
Jesus's second coming and verse 30 we
find the word Tata again then the sign
of the son of man will appear in heaven
and then all the tribes of the earth
will mourn and they will see the son of
man coming in the Clouds Of Heaven with
power and great Glory so what is the
sequence let's summarize it there is a
time of uncertainty a time of distress
that is the time we are living right now
then we will find the the beginning of
the little time of trouble when the
persecution begins we're being accused
for keeping Sabbath and
and it'll be urged upon us that it is
because we are keeping Sabbath that
God's judgments are falling on the Earth
this
as a result of this many will be thrown
into prison then we find
that the preaching of the Gospel at the
beginning of the loud cry which bibli
intensify when the Sunday law the mark
of the beast will be enforced with that
comes the ceiling with that comes the
latter rain of course and then we have
close approvation
closer provision then Begins the time of
trouble the great time of trouble and
the plagues Begin to Fall
and within that time of trouble Jesus
doesn't really specify this year we have
a smaller time a shorter time that is
called the time of Jacob's trouble
and this time goes between the second or
the third plague and the sixth play when
God's people will be delivered okay why
is it called Jacob's time of trouble
because the 144 000 who will be leaving
during this time will experience
something similar to Jacob when he was
being persecuted by ESO his brother okay
then we have God's people delivered
under the Sixth plague then we have the
seventh plague and then the coming of
Jesus so we are very close to the end of
time and may we be faithful when Jesus
comes so that he may found us uh
faithful in his sight so this is just a
summary I highly recommend that you
watch Pastor board series on Matthew 24
where he goes into more details in
regards to this sequence you can find it
in our website in our YouTube channel
and also if you download our app you
should be able to find the series and
the study guides there as well
okay
I hope that answered your question
the next question comes from Tom wall
and the question says
I'd like to know what is meant in John
10 verse 18.
where Jesus said he had the authority to
lay down his life and to take it back
again
it seems clear in Galatians 1 1 and
Romans 6 4 and in many places in the
book of Acts that it was God the father
that raised Jesus from the dead
so what is meant by I have the authority
to take my life back
is it also then correct to say that it
was the father that raised Jesus from
the dead
not Jesus raising himself
thank you
this is a very good question that you
have asked Tom very very important
question
because we find this apparent dichotomy
between some of these texts so I would
like to read the text that you're
mentioned and then I would like to also
add other Bible verses that deal with
the same question so the first text that
we find
uh that you quoted here is John
chapter 10 and verse 18. John chapter 10
and verse 18 this is Jesus speaking and
it says no one takes it from me but I
lay it down this is talking about
Jesus's life but I lay it down
and I have power to take it again
this command I have received from my
father
so Jesus clearly saying here that he has
power to lay down and he has power to
take it back again his life so clearly
Jesus is saying here that first of all
he is God because only God has Life
original and borrowed and underived so
Jesus is saying here he is God because
he has the power to lay his life and to
take it back again but then why then as
Romans 6 4 he also quoted Galatians 1 1
but I'm just going to go ahead and read
Romans 6 4 therefore we were buried with
him that is Jesus Through baptism into
death that just as Christ was raised
from the dead by the glory of the father
even so we also should walk in newness
of life so here it says that Jesus was
raised from the dead by the glory of the
father so who is the one resurrecting
here Jesus is the father it's very clear
now there is a text that you did not
quote
Romans chapter 8 verse 11 now things are
going to get more complicated here
because now it says in this text that it
was the Holy Spirit that raised Jesus
it says but if the spirit of him who
raised Jesus from the dead dwells in you
he who raised Christ from the dead will
also give you life to your mortal bodies
to his Spirit who dwells in you huh so
we have Jesus he says he has the power
to take his life back again we have hear
the father that raised up Jesus from the
dead but we have also the holy spirit
that raised up Jesus from the dead
but then Matthew 28 verse 2 it gets even
more complicated
because now it says that it was an angel
that came to the tune
Matthew 28 verse 2 and behold there was
a great earthquake for an angel of the
Lord descended from heaven and came and
rolled back the Stone from the door and
sat on it
now Ellen White describes it like this
when this Angel comes the Earth this is
Desire of Ages page 779
the Earth trembles at his approach the
host of Darkness flee and as he rolls
away the stone Heaven seems to come down
to the Earth
the soldiers seen him Revolt removing
the stone as he would a pebble
and hear him cry Son of God come forth
the father calls thee
they see Jesus comfort from the grave
and hear him Proclaim over the rent
Sepulcher I am the resurrection and the
life he comes forth in majesty and Glory
the angel hose bowel low in adoration
before the Redeemer and welcome him with
songs of praise
so how do we reconcile all this well
when we understand how Heaven works
and the chain of command in the order of
heaven then we will realize that all the
godhead is involved in this work
how does heaven work
let's go to the Book of Revelation
chapter 1 and we're going to see here
the chain of command
Revelation chapter 1
and verse one and two actually just
verse one it says the revelation of
Jesus Christ
which God this is the father gave him
Jesus to show his servants
things which must shortly take place
and he
sent
and signified it by his angel
to his servant John
so notice here the chain of command God
the Father give Jesus a revelation sends
it by his Angel to his servant John who
is the prophet now before John receives
it actually even before the angel
receives it who's the one that gives it
to the angel when we go to Revelation
Chapter 2 and 3 where we find the
message to the seven churches we find
over and over this doxology
verse 7 for example of Revelation
Chapter 2 he who has an ear let him hear
what the spirit says to the churches so
who is the one that is addressing the
churches the spirit so this is the chain
of command you have got the father
he gives the order to Jesus Jesus gives
it to the Holy Spirit the holy spirit
gives it to the angel the angel gives it
to the prophet that's why the prophets
in the bible we see them every time
they're envisioned
we see that there is an angel revealing
to them the vision but we say that it is
the holy spirit that inspires the
authors but it's actually the Holy
Spirit sending an angel
Ellen White had the same experience we
see her describing an angel in her
Visions but the angel is sent by the
Holy Spirit who is sent by Jesus who is
sent by the father that is the heavenly
side of the chain what is the Earthly
side of the chain well the prophet has
the choice of communicating the message
of not the prophet is to communicate it
to according to revelation
to the angels of each churches which are
God's ministers okay the angels are
God's ministers
the minister is supposed to communicate
it to
the church members and the churches come
is supposed to communicate it to the
world
and that's the side that sometimes gets
broken because the message comes
directly from Heaven all the way to the
prophet from the prophet onward it can
get broken okay so the same thing here
we see God the father gives the order
because as we read in the in this quote
thy father calls the so God the Father
gave the order this time since Jesus was
sleeping therefore we skip that step and
it goes to the Holy Spirit
who sends the angel Gabriel and now
Jesus when he hears his words he
understands that now the father is
giving him permission to take his life
and resurrect with his own divinity
so this is what happened exactly here
in Jesus's resurrection
very good in the few minutes that we
have I will try to
answer
this question from Anita magru
she says I know and I really like this
question very sincere question
and I know many people struggle with
this I know when I repent
from my I know when I Repent my sin goes
into the sanctuary
does that mean I am not fully forgiven
until the day of atonement is over and
Michael stands up
my sin remain if my sins remain if
they're in the century scary to realize
my sin exists even after I Repent I need
guidance understanding this
thank you
well this is something that many
Christians struggle today and Desmond 4
actually used this argument to challenge
the doctrine of the sanctuary and the
investigative judgment
so the bottom line of the question is
can I have the Assurance of of Salvation
in view of the Heavenly judgment
and the answer is a resounding yes you
can have the Assurance of Salvation
because the fact that your sins are
recorded in heaven doesn't mean that you
are not forgiven actually it means the
other way around it means that you are
forgiven and they no longer belong to
you
now they belong to the sanctuary this
goes as if when we go to Jesus
and we confess our sins he's the one
that bears our sins
uh where do their sins go well he's
bearing our sins
but that is no longer ours because we
have given them to him so the sanctuary
functions in the same way now when when
we go to Daniel let's for a moment try
to understand the nature of the Judgment
because sometimes we think of the
Judgment as a scene where God is going
to just punish us and condemn us but
that's not what the judgment is about
here we find a different picture of the
Judgment in Daniel chapter 7 verse 9 it
says I watched till Thrones were put in
place and the Ancient of Days were
seated His Garment was wide as us now so
this is a scene of judgment Thrones are
placed put in place but I want to go to
the end of verse 10. it says a thousand
times a thousand thousands minister to
him Ten Thousand Times Ten Thousand
stood before him the court was seated
uh and the books were open
so here we see that there is a vision of
judgment but then when we go uh further
in this chapter we're told that judgment
is given
in favor of the Saints verse 22 and I
like how the new King James version
translates it not like other versions
but it uses the expression in favor it
says in verse 22 until the Ancient of
Days came and judgment was made in favor
of the Saints of the most high and the
time came for the Saints to possess the
kingdom in other words the judgment is
in our favor if we have
registered our sins in the Heavenly
Century by faith
so we should not be afraid of the
Judgment if we have sincerely confessed
our sins and given them to Jesus because
the judgment is
in favor of the judgment is not to
change our standing before God the
Judgment has an eschatological purpose
of vindicate the character of God before
the universe he's being accused of being
unjust then God now is going to show his
righteousness by forgiving justifying
and taking to Heaven those that have
repented since God since God knows our
hearts he knows that it is safe to take
us to heaven but the Heavenly Angels do
not know therefore the judgment is to
reveal before the universe that he is
right when he says that he wants to take
us to Heaven well God bless you and
thank you for being with us in this
program see you next time
foreign
[Music]